the rake is a man who has an intense  interest in women he understands them  deeply but one woman can never satisfy  him the only way he can get satisfaction  is by constantly having new women in his  life the moment that a woman becomes  familiar it kind of loses the edge that  he wants he loves the process of  seducing her of getting her to fall for  him in those first few weeks he showers  her with attention he love bombs them  he's so excited about their world he  gives them gifts that show he's thinking  about them he takes them to exciting  places it's irresistible but the thing  is it can't last because he has to  continually find new people to conquer